have you ever gotten back with an ex uh
oh my god around the bend
let's serve up some news sunny side up
to the sex and the city reboot there's
some fresh
news out w magazine reports that while
samantha won't be
back the show has announced plans to add
three
new friends to the group they are all
women of color
and they say well just like in real life
some friendships
fade as new ones grow and bloom in the
garden and they've also confirmed
that aiden will be back i happen to have
been a fan of aiden i love when he says
the
the flaws the best part you know um
listen here's the deal i'm excited there
will be new friends because we're still
mourning samantha
i love that there's going to be
diversity on the show yeah but bottom
line
i need to know what carrie's doing and i
need to know about uh
miranda and charlotte that's all i want
the rest
great i'm happy you know if you get a
buffet
here we go with the buffet i love it you
want your mains
and then you can have side dishes as
well but i i need my main dishes
i i agree a writer at purewow says that
she
and her husband improved their
connection and even cut down on fights
by using the
half glass of wine technique the idea
came from her therapist and it's simple
schedule a half glass of wine with your
partner every night and when you sit
down to play catch up
the only rule is that you can't talk
logistics or to do is
just focus on each other okay amber
you're married to
actor andrew west so what do you
think of this and ross i want to know
what you and wellington are going to
think amber you first i'm
this is brilliant i think it's a great
idea this is how we got through the
pandemic
and i can't wait to do it again when
this person gets out of my body
[Laughter]
i love that i think it's so important to
make that time to connect
my only problem with this half glass of
wine challenge not enough
she can be a half bottle of wine hello i
totally agree
people reports that saturday night lives
pete davidson
the resident cutie who's reportedly
dating actress phoebe denivere
says that his key is total
and complete honesty he isn't into
playing games he says that he's always
up front
he says this is who i am these are my
issues
here's the whole deal unfiltered sunny
thoughts i've been married for almost
23 years lots of talk and
i think pete is really sexy
really cute that's why he gets all the
hot girls he's really
funny is always really good um complete
honesty
i think he's on the wrong track there um
i think when you first get into a
relationship
um you need to send your representative
right because the person isn't really
hooked yet
so it's not about showing the good the
bad and the ugly it's just
showing the good it's showing the best
it's showing
what you could be it's trying to be the
best version of yourself
then once you're in it once the person's
hooked once the person's in love
works come out that's when the crazy
crazy the independent says rumors are
swirling have you seen this
jennifer lopez yeah and ben affleck are
rekindling the romance after
17 years remember they were benifer
oh it changed everything we now
put everybody's name in a mashup because
of benefer well yeah they were the first
and now they're benefited 2.0
people are thinking therapists say
though is this a good idea to get back
with your ex
they say before you get back together
you should examine why you broke up in
the first place
and try this imagine that you never met
your ex before
and if you met them now as strangers
would you be totally attracted
because it's like are you just thinking
about how good it was at one point
the romance of that hmm have you ever
gotten back with an ex
oh my god around the bend
if i dated 17 years ago a guy
i am so not the same person my issues
back then would
not be my issues now
there it goes and today for someone
looking for something real juicy and a
real page turner
it's a brand new mystery called the last
thing he told me by laura dave
it follows a woman who forms an
unexpected relationship
with her teenage stepdaughter as she
tries to solve the mystery
of her new husband's sudden
disappearance it's so hot
it's a pick from reese witherspoon's
book club you see the sticker
it's right there reese's book club and
it's already being adapted into a
limited series
for apple tv plus starring the one and
only julia robert
oh oh i've heard of her yeah yeah so
that's why this book is super hot
you